the jurogan experience just to give you
an example in my book i talk about
winston churchill winston church 1939
wrote an essay about the fact that there
could be life around other in on other
planets around other stars and
we should search for it now he didn't
have a chance to publish it because he
became prime minister
and then had to fight the the second
world war against the nazi regime
so much money was wasted in that war if
that money was allocated to
the search for extraterrestrial life the
way the churchill envisioned it before
the war
we might have we might have known the
answer by now
and what i'm saying is this is just an
example for how
non-intelligent we are we are not
working together towards a better future
we are fighting each other and that's
the answer to your question that we
might not
live very long but you're saying this as
you work at
harvard and as you're writing books on
extraterrestrial objects
right i don't necessarily agree with you
i think there are
massive problems with people but i think
we are far better than the human beings
that live 2000 years ago in that regard
and i think that we will probably be
looking back on this day and age and
mocking how stupid we are when we are
more advanced two thousand
i really hope so and that's what i'm
trying we're moving in that direction
well that's what i'm trying to promote
but
i'm not necessarily as optimistic as you
are i think our cake is still in the
oven
let's hope so i really want that future
but
you know i'm doing my best but you can
see from the pushback
yes to which i don't have access because
i i'm not
you know i don't have a an account on
the social congratulations again for
that
i think that's i i think we're moving
i think there's conflict but i think for
whatever reason
the way human beings operate we
oftentimes
need conflict in order to make
improvements right we need a yin and
yang we needed a given a poll if we
don't have that
we get we get complacent why can't we
understand the
the best path forward without you know
it's just like
using a gps system and it says
recalculating
every time we have a crisis
recalculating so we
recalculate our next move based on all
the mistakes we've made
why can't we be smart in the first place
i think we have biological limitations
that are based on our ancestry
and our ancestry is filled with
tribalism and chaos and
we're primates i mean that's that's part
of the problem and i think that
our issue with racism is the same issue
that we have
when we have religious discrimination or
cultural discrimination
it's tribalism i agree and we are you
know we're just it's wired into our dna
now my problem is why couldn't science
given that you know there are billions
of
earth sun systems within just the milky
way galaxy
and then a trillion galaxies like the
milky way in the
observable volume of the universe you
know
why can't the mainstream of astronomy
simply say conservatively you know just
assuming the most conservative not
speculative
assumption conservatively we are at the
middle of the road
you know kind of life uh it's very
likely that we're not unique and special
and let's just look for evidence you
know search for it
why should that there be a taboo on
discussing this subject that makes no
sense
for example astronomers are now thinking
contemplating
new telescopes of the future that will
cost
billions of dollars to taxpayers okay
that would search for oxygen in the
atmospheres of other planets around
other stars
because oxygen could be indicative of
life microbial life
i say it will never be conclusive such a
search even if it costs billions of
dollars because
the earth for two billion years the
first two billion years of the earth
history
didn't have much oxygen it's in its
atmosphere there were microbes
but the oxygen level was quite low and
then it suddenly rose after two billion
years half of its life
so not finding oxygen doesn't mean there
is no life and then if you find oxygen
it can be produced by many natural
processes
like breaking water molecules or other
things so it will never be conclusive
how can you make a conclusive statement
if you find industrial pollution
in the same atmosphere you just search
for cfcs these are the
molecules produced by refrigerating
systems by
industries if you find evidence for that
there is no way that nature can make
these
very complex molecules naturally so i
say to the mainstream of astronomy use
the same instruments
and motivate them by this question of
can we detect industrial pollution
and i wrote a paper but and the thing is
the public is extremely interested in
this question
and the public funds science
so how can the scientific community shy
away from a question that it can address
with existing technology you know
when the public is very interested in
that how can there be a taboo on this
question
that's the thing that really puzzles me
now you know i wasn't working in this
area until the last
five years or so i was working in
studying
black holes studying the universe and i
came across
a number of ideas that led me in into
this
rabbit hole into this subject now i'm
about to
publish this book at a popular level but
also a textbook
six months later that describes all the
signs that we have
related to the search for life outside
earth far from earth
and i'm just amazed that
it's not part of the mainstream you know
it's really surprising to me and i think
it's inappropriate because you look at
physics theoretical physics
there are lots of speculative ideas in
it like people talk about extra
dimensions
the multiverse you know super symmetry
super string theory
all of these have no evidence to their
credit
you know there is no experimental test
not even
thought about you know like in the next
decade the next two decades
but these ideas are part of the
mainstream so
you see physicists giving each other
awards
and doing intellectual gymnastics you
know just demonstrating that they're
smart
and to me that's an unhealthy situation
in physics you know you can do it in
mathematics where it's completely
detached from
any application to reality but in
physics we are supposed to describe
reality and yet you have this intellect
so it's as if the physics community
some parts of it decided that the most
important
task is to demonstrate that you're smart
and that is really strange to me because
you know we're supposed to understand
nature
not show that we are smart catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify you can listen to
the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience